>> Okay.
Thank you everyone for coming.
We're very happy to
have Soledad Villar
visiting us today and tomorrow.
Soledad did her PhD with
Rachel Ward at UT Austin,
and she's now a postdoc
with Afonso Bandeira at NYU,
and she will tell us
about Quadratic Assignment
on Data models.
>> Okay. Thank you so
much for inviting me.
Okay. So, I'm going to talk
about Quadratic assignment.
If you haven't seen the
quadratic assignment problem,
what it does is like
you have A and B.
They are n by n matrices,
and you can see a pie,
the set of n by
n permutation matrices,
and the quadratic assignment
problem ask for the maximum
among all X in the set of n
by n permutation matrices,
of the trace of A times
X times B times X transpose.
This is a quadratic
assignment problem.
This is a very general problem
in theoretical computer science,
and it includes
many relevant problems
as particular cases.
One of the problems
is graph matching,
where you have the graph A
and the graph B,
and you want to find
the best match in
between these two graphs.
So, if you can write it
as the minimizing of
AX minus XB square,
and then when you
expand the square,
you get AX square,
XB square, and then this term
that is exactly this thing.
>> Wait, why isn't it
equivalent to [inaudible]
>> Because when you expand
the square, this is constant.
And this is constant because
this square should be outside.
And then, the inner problem
between AX and
XB is exactly the traits of
these times these transpose.
>> What I meant was just,
it's not the sub case of
the quadratic
assignment. It covers-
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> It's for symmetric like ANG-
>>Yes, yes, yes
>>Yeah. Yeah. So, then,
the graph isomorphism problem
is deciding whether to
graph our isomorphic is deciding
whether the axis matching
with objective value zero,
is also a particular case
of quadratic assignment.
And the travelling
salesman problem, which us,
given a set of points in
nuclear space or
like a matrix space,
you want to find the best path
that covers every point and
minimizes some of the distances.
And that is the same as asking
matching between
the distance square matrix,
the pairwise distance matrix,
and a complete cycle.
Right. So, and another problem
that can be posed
as a quadratic assignment is
the Gromov-Hausdorff distance
of finite metric spaces.
And, I'm going to talk about
it, a little bit in this talk.
And, something to note is that,
this problem is simply hard
even to approximate it,
but the philosophy. Yes.
>> Is the graph
isomorphism problem
is lower than NP-hard?
>>So, the graph isomorphism
problem is a particular case.
It's not equivalent.
Yes. And there is
a polylog algorithm to,
that is very recent
to solve there.
Try and say, [inaudible].
So, yeah, the graph isomorphism.
Sorry. Yeah. Okay. So, so
being NP-hard is
a statement about
the worst-case
instance, instance.
But NP-hard problems can be
tractable for
a large set of instances,
even a dense set of instances.
And the real data
is not adversarial,
so we are going to focus on
a set of worst case complexity,
in like some, some data moles,
where we can solve the problem,
and what we can do for
different data moles.
Okay. So we're gonna talk
about different techniques that
we can use for this,
for this problem.
First I'm going to talk about
semidefinite programming,
then the projected
power iteration,
and some graph neural networks.
So the first part,
I'm going to talk
aboutsemidefinite programming
and the Gromov-Hausdorff
distance.
And this is a project
I did during my PhD.
And my collaborators are
Alfonso Bandeira who is in NYU;
Andrew Blumberg who
is in UT Austin,
he's a professor in
algebraic topology;
and Rachel Ward who
was my PhD adviser.
>> Can I just ask
a question, calls it TSP?
>> Yes.
>> Why? It's not
equal to maximizing?
I mean you are trying to match
the cycle to avert
the cycle into the,
into the complete work
with the distances?
And when I, when I
do that, why is it-
>> Well, you can,
negate one of the matrices
as a function on change.
Yeah, you can change
the max for a mean.
>> But I square.
>> Sorry?
>> Okay. Because I square,
don't you, I mean,
negating doesn't matter
because you square everything.
When do you get a forbidden sum?
>> And, in the linear,
in this formulation it doesn't.
Right? You can consider
the trace of A, BX, and then-
>> In matrices, okay.
>> The commands for
mean is the same.
So, okay.
So I'm going to talk about the,
the a Hausdorff distance.
I'm going to find
the Hausdorff distance first.
So if X and Y are compact sets
in a metric space,
then you can define
the distance from a point here,
to the point in X
that's set in Y,
as the distance to the point
that minimizes
the distance in the outset.
And then you can define
the distance between X and Y,
as you take among all the
distances from points to Y,
you take the infimum,
sorry the supremum.
And then, since this definition
is not symmetric between
X and Y and Y and X,
then you define
the Hausdorff distance as
the max between
d(X,Y) and d(Y, X).
And, so this is
the distance between
two sets that are embedded
in the same metric space.
They are compact sets
in the metric space.
So the Gromov-Haudsorff
distance is defined for
two compact metric
spaces that are
not necessarily embedded
in the same space.
The way it is defined is if
X and Y are
compact metric spaces,
then you consider
all isometric embeddings,
from X to Z and from Y to Z,
to a larger space Z.
And then, you define
the distance between X and
Y as the Hausdorff distance
between F of X,
the embedding of X and
the embedding of Y.
And then you take
the infimum among
all possible
isometric embeddings.
And this looks hard to compute.
But then we'll see
how to compute it,
and then fact is
that the
Gromov-Haudsorff distance
between two metric
spaces is zero,
even a leaf, this pen
is isometric.
This is the natural distance
between metric spaces.
It has interesting results and
applications in
Riemannian Geometry,
and it has been introduced
by Gromov in order to prove
the famous Gromov theorem
on growth like groups
of polynomial growth.
That says that, if you have
a final generator group,
and then you take
a number of generators.
And then, you see
how many elements
of the group you can write as
a combination of
these generators.
And if that grows
polynomially in
the number of generators,
then it means that your group
has a large part that
is Abelia, like commute.
So, in our case,
we're going to I think of
Gromov-Hausdorff distance
in point clouds.
And one motivation to think of
all these point clouds
is because if you
have X and Y on they are
compact matrix spaces,
then you can consider
extra epsilon-nets,
which is subsets where
every point in
your manifold is within
epsilon of one point in
your epsilon-net, at least.
And then, if you
take epsilon-net of X
and epsilon-net of Y,
and they you take
epsilon ten to zero,
then the distance
between X and Y is
the limit with epsilon ten to
zero of the distance
between the epsilon-nets.
So, it's a good approximation to
computing in point
close to actually,
computed in the
whole metric space.
And you can use this to
compare geometric objects,
like surfaces.
But also, for example,
this is a paper in 2011 in
PNAS by speaker Daubachies
and collaborators,
where they use something
similar to
Gromov-Hausdorff distance
like using optimum transport.
They call it the
Gromov-Hausdorff distance
to compare some teeth and they
use it to use produce a taxonomy
and like using
the distances between
these teeth and produce
taxonomy in the species that
they wanted to classify.
So, they used it for
scientific applications.
But also, you may want to use
these to the spaces where
the geometry is less apparent,
like naming sequences
or two spaces,
where you cannot-
like in this case,
they use optimal transport,
and they use the geometry
of the space.
But maybe if you don't
have a geometric space
where you can use the geometry.
Just like some metric
spaces, like trees.
Maybe you want
an algorithmic approach
for these kind of
problems as well.
So, if you have
these two metric spaces,
and they're finite, how are
we going to compute
the Gromov-Hausdorff distance?
So, well, let's say
that X has X1 to Xn,
and Y is Y1 to Ym,
then we are going to
say that Delta ij is
1 if Xi is related with
Yj and 0 otherwise,
we're going to find
this large matrix Gamma
with N this is ij,kl.
The parallel
distances between Xi
and Xk minus the distance
between Yj and Yi.
So, we make these like,
N by M times N by
M matrix Gamma.
And then, you can write
the quadratic
assignment theorem as
the following
optimization problem.
That it's going to be, so,
you take this N matrix
and then take among
all possible relations
between X and
Y so that every element in
X has a correspondence Y,
and every element Y has
a correspondence in X.
You take the max entrance of
the correspondent like
Xi within Yj are related.
And if Yj,
if these two points are related
and these points are related,
then you take the ending
of this matrix.
Does that make sense? So,
this is a formulation by
Facundo Mémoli in
2007. So, you can-
>> And so, somehow you
assume that every point
to next is assigned to
some points on Y and vice versa?
>> Yes. So, among
all possible relations that
every element in
Y is assigned to
at least one element in X-
>> But, what's
the physical meaning of it?
Like it can be
at some points sum
of match to anything.
>> Sorry?
>> So,
in this way optimal embedding
of everything in the Z.
Some points might not
be match to each other.
I mean, you even
cut the picture,
like you cut like two
these sort of pictures,
some of the points
will just like.
So, can you explain, why this
is a problem to
Gromov-Hausdorff?
Like if go over
there. Yeah. This one.
>> Yeah.
>> So, can you explain,
like how we get deltas?
>> So, when you take
the distance between,
like let's say,
F of X and G of Y,
then for each point you
consider if the supremum
on to the points to
the other points.
>> Now I get it.
So it's equal to the closest
point that in the imbedding?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Does that make sense? So, it
comes from here basically.
So, since you need to
take this supremum,
then every point needs to be
connect. So, it's kind of-
>> If you go back to
the previous slide, in this one,
the equivalent you
could just say that
they forget about
just a house of distance,
is the smallest epsilon,
such that X is within
a ball of radius of
Y and vice versa.
>> Get it.
>> Right?
>> Yeah.
>> And if you think about
that, and it's equivalent.
>> So, this
formulation is doing,
is taking Z to be
the product between X and Y.
So, basically, what am I
going to do is
I'm going to relax
these optimization problems in
a very similar way by
lifting this delta as
an indicator director.
And so, this is
a quadratic in delta,
but it's linear in
the outer product of
delta with itself.
So, we have this
and then first I'm going
to relax the max to a sum.
Just to make it a differential.
And then, we consider
delta Z to be delta probe,
delta to itself, and
then delta ij is (0,1),
you can relax this also
to delta between 0 and 1.
And so, if you see this sum,
it's actually the trace of
this Z matrix times
the Gamma matrix.
So, a way to relax
is, for example,
if you have the
correct normalization,
instead of asking that
delta is rank one,
you can relax these to be
trace one and possibly
a semi-definite,
and then the interest of
Z between zero and one.
And this is like a standard way
of relaxing
this kind of problem.
>> But maximum will
sounds like horrible idea,
so the fact that it
works reasonably well,
that's kind of fucking
to me actually.
>> Yeah, okay.
We'll do something else.
Okay. So basically now,
you used to have a function
defined in a discrete set,
and now we have a convex set
that includes
these discrete set,
and we are defining another
function in this relaxed set.
So basically, we
had what you said,
we had this max like
an infinity norm,
and we are relaxing it
to a one norm, the trace.
So these I already said.
But now, what we're
going to do is,
we're going to consider in
fact a family of relaxation.
So, we have like infinity,
like what you said,
relaxing into from infinity to
one norm is not
necessarily really good.
But something that you can do,
is you can relax
these to a P norm,
and make P tend to infinity.
In fact, you can consider
family of relaxations of
Gromov-Hausdorff distance.
So, for each P, you have
that the P relaxed distance
between X and Y is the P norm
of that relaxation.
And then you can make
P as large as you want.
Okay. And so, you
can add from here,
sorry I'm going back.
So here, this is like
just the standard way,
but then you can add
a linear constraint
to make your problem
tighter depending
on the shape of
your problem and
the constraints that you have.
And so, if you add
certain set of constraints,
for example in this case,
when the number of points
in X and Y is equal to N,
that is the same.
Then you can actually
decide to consider
more or less constraints
to make it tighter.
So basically, this is like
a family of distances.
What you say is like,
well, we don't know
there's a distance yet,
but we consider
this optimization problem,
that is a relaxation of
the Gromov-Hausdorff distance.
And then, for
each P, the output,
the number of the value of
the optimization problem,
we're going to call this
the relaxed dp of X and Y.
And we see that,
in fact this dp for
all P satisfies
the triangle inequality.
So, it's actually that distance.
So, the value of
that optimization problem
is actually a semi-metric.
In fact, it's not
very metric. Yes?
>> I guess I'm jumping
ahead but this P is
like N two for variables.
So, there's something that
needs computing theorem. Okay.
>> Yes, you're right.
Yeah. So, you can show that
this relaxed distance is
also monotonic as the P norm
using a clear space.
And if X and Y are isometric,
then it's also a lower bound for
the Gromov-Hausdorff distance
because there's a relaxation.
And then, if X and
Y are isometric,
then the relaxed distance
between X and Y is zero,
and the isometry is a solution
of the semi-definite program,
but is not true the converse,
like it may have been
that the distance between
X and Y relaxed can be zero
for non-isometric X and Y.
And this is because the graph
isomorphism can be posed as
deciding whether
the Gromov-Hausdorff distance
between two graphs is zero,
and it's known that
the graph isomorphism
cannot be solve
with sum of squares.
And so, there is
an explicit example
that you can construct,
that sum of squares
cannot distinguish between
isomorphic and
non-isomorphic graphs,
and there is an explicit
construction using 3XOR,
and then you can construct
the graph A and
graph B, and then,
if you look at these,
these are not isomorphic.
But if you look at the
semi-definite program, from it,
you can extract
a soft assignment
that has subjective value zero,
and it's not two.
It shows, yeah?
>> Where is the sum
of squares on that?
>> Well, you can write
sum squares as
semi-definite program.
>> But probably
what they shouldn't,
I only expect that probably they
should wait for
convex sum of squares.
>> Yeah, they shall wait
for that particular,
but then, if you say.
>> But it's equivalent
to dp or something?
The convex sum of squares
for graph isomorphism?
>> It's not equivalent,
but the same example,
like the same construction.
It also works for
this case. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So, something
that you can consider
is that, okay,
so now, we have
this relaxed distance,
it's a semi-metric.
And we may want to
say what topological
properties it has,
what is the convergence
on this metric, et cetera.
And so, something that
you can see is that,
if you have X and
all pairwise distances
within X are different,
you can consider why
that is isometric to X,
and then you can see that
the semi-definite program
has a unique solution.
In that case, where
all pairwise distances
in metric space are different,
has a unique solution,
that is isometry, and of course,
the relaxed distance
between X and Y is zero.
But also, small
perturbations of X and Y,
let's say you fix
X and you make
a small perturbation in Y,
because of the shape of
the optimization problem,
the solution is like an extreme
point of your convex set.
If you make
a small perturbation,
you will obtain
the same solution.
So, that shows that in
a local neighborhood of X,
then the distances,
Gromov-Hausdorff distance and
relax distance are equivalent.
And therefore, you have that
this relax distance is
a polynomial time proxy
for the Gromov-Hausdorff
distance,
that is locally equivalent
in a dense set of points.
And outside, our local
neighborhood of X,
these distances
are not equivalent.
So therefore, the
compact metric spaces
where the Gromov-Hausdorff
distance the basic.
Then since these metric
is not equivalent,
then here it's not just basic,
so the topology is
very, very different.
Okay. And so, what
Elia was asking,
okay computing this
is actually very
complicated because it's
a very large
semi-definite program.
So, you can do
some non-convex
efficient algorithm
to find a correspondence,
or to approximate these
using AVMM for example,
but of course, you don't
have a proof of
convergence to the optimal.
And you can find
a local minimum of
the objective function,
for example in
the correspondence case.
And there is some recent work
by the group of Singer,
where they consider very
similar semi-definite program
in a case for graphs,
and then they've reduced
the complexity of
the semi-definite program
by a factor of N,
by further relaxing this dp
in the sense of they
have this constraint,
instead of asking that the
whole matrix is semi-definite,
they take relevance of matrices,
and they ask those relevance
of matrices to be semi-definite.
>> I'm confusing, what
is non-convex here?
Didn't you say that it is a SDP?
>> You can use non-convex
approach to this SDP.
Yeah, like AVMM or something.
>> Too many only work
in a reckless specimens.
>> Yes. Yeah. Or maybe you
can use some Boreal Montero,
where you use more
than rank one.
Like you factor the matrix
that say a transpose,
and you do some get in the sand
there for example
not just rank one.
So, you avoid
local minima in that way.
But of course,
proving some result
with respect to
those distances is hard.
>> I don't get where
when we bury P,
where do we gain them?
>> So, when you bury P,
you get closer to
the Gromov-Hausdorff distance.
>> Just intuitively or is
a formal way to say that.
>> There is a way you
can say it is here.
>> Just this way?
>> Yeah, of course you can
study how this will depend
on P and Q. I didn't do it.
And also see how
this depends on P and Q
and make some numeric.
I didn't do it, so I don't know.
>> Do we know something about
the gap between
the infinity and the GH?
>> Yes, we know
some examples where,
for example, this is
non-zero and this is zero.
>> Yeah, I'm sure you
said it, it's all right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, is there
more questions about this?
>> So, are we going
to see the animation?
>> Do you want to see it?
>> Maybe towards the end.
>> At the end. Yes, let's see.
Okay. I have an animation
in my website, but I don't know.
>> So I guess,
the initial hope was
I guess relaxation.
So that it's like useful proxy
for Gromov-Hausdorff applications
or something like this.
So how far we have from
this being the case?
You know we're we able
to use it on some,
so you hold some source
or something like this.
>> Some of the review was I
reproduce the results from
the [inaudible] paper using the
Gromov-Hausdorff of distance.
I actually could
reproduce the results
using this relaxation
between the t's.
>> So if I want to Gromov-Hausdorff
distance between cells
then I should use three people
more reasonably well.
>> So there's two things.
If you want a compute
a number as the distance.
Or if you want to
find the matching.
So if you want to
find the matching,
of course you can get
a number as the distance but
then you don't have these
topological properties
that we saw.
If you want to do
an experiment where you
only care about the number,
then you may want to find like,
for example use the Amit
Singer code for running
this LCPN obtained
in this number.
So what I did was,
I reproduced it
with the CTN.
>> So what's the largest set of
points that these codes
can handle realistically?
>> I'm not sure,
but I think, I did it in
my computer with 50 points,
which is not a lot.
>> We used P plus
1 or some other P?
>> Yeah, P equals 1.
So, now I'm going
to talk about
the different flavor of
algorithm that I will apply
to a very similar problem.
That is Projected
Power Iteration.
And the case that
I'm thinking of
now is a graft matching.
So there is this EigenAlign
algorithm that given A and B,
the two graphs, you construct
Gamma matrix very similar to
the one that we had before.
That Gamma is going to be one.
So you have these two graphs
on I are is on edge.
In the first graph on J prime,
S prime. Very sorry.
In the second graph
and you put out
one if you are in this case,
and you put a zero if you
are in a different case.
So basically you have an edge
here and an edge here,
you put on one and
then zero otherwise.
The algorithm, just
a simple thing,
you take the top eigenvector of
Gamma and you round
it to a permutation.
>> How do you do the rounding?
>> Yes, that's
a very good question.
So something that you
can do is you can solve
a linear problem and
you maximize it with
a Birkhoff polytope.
So given this vector,
you write it as a matrix
like a square matrix
and then you take
the maximum of that,
times X such that X is
bistochastic and then you
know that the solution
of that linear problem
is going to
be integer because
all the vertices are goal.
>> [inaudible] could
you repeat the process?
>> So what you do is you have
these top eigenvectors you
write it as a matrix and then
you consider the max
of that vector
in a [inaudible] with X
such that X is bistochastic.
>> X is matrix.
>> A matrix, that is correct.
>> But it's still fractional,
right? Whatever you [inaudible].
>> No, because all-
>> Yeah, yeah sure [inaudible].
>> So these algorithms will work
in a very, very few instances.
For example, if Gamma is
not the top eigenvector,
it's not simple,
like there's more
than one eigenvector with
the same eigenvalue, then
it's not going to work.
And if you have a lot of
noise then it's also
not going to work.
But that's like a base line.
So basically what we want
to do is we want to modify
this algorithm to see
if we can make it work
in a more general case.
So this comes from
the idea that,
for example, when you
want to go clustering,
you can consider
spectral clustering.
You take, let's say,
that you want to
find two clusters to
take a top eigenvector of
a distance matrix or
Laplacian and then and
then you see
this top eigenvector
works in a very good case
where the clusters
are separated,
but sometimes you
can actually modify.
While the when you take
the top eigenvector and
then you get the clustering
works better in that case.
And this is work that is
very precise and is work by
Emmanuel Abbe and
Andrea Montanari
and they study
algorithms of these form.
Like what is
the best spectrum method
for this clustering problem.
So this is basically
what we want to do here.
Like, look for
a good spectrum method
in this quadratic
assignment problem.
So we're going to consider
projected power iteration
where one can think of the..
>> In this equation,
what's the problem
we're solving?
>> We're going to find
the matching A and B,
two graphs and we
want to find matching.
>> So we match, so it's like
we want permutation on one
to one type of
vertices so that what, what's
the objective function?
>> The same as before. Right?
>> Graph isomorphism?
>> Sorry?
>> Yes.
>> I see. So we get one
for every age that got
matched otherwise zero
in all three cases. Okay.
>> So.
>> So number of common ages.
>> So you want to,
maximize the trace of
AX BX transpose and X.
>> Okay, so we're solving
genome problem but
for the case where A
and B are 01 matrices.
>> Yeah.
>> And they are
symmetric on levels?
>> Symmetric, yeah.
>> Okay, okay.
>> So we're going to go and see
a projected power iteration.
And the idea is that when
you take the top eigenvector,
you can do it using
a power method.
You start with a vector and then
you multiply the matrix
times the vector,
and you multiply that times
the matrix again and
again until convergence.
The projected power iteration,
what it does is it adds
thresholding step after
each iteration of
the power method.
So instead of multiplying
matrix times
matrix times vector,
you do matrix times vector
and then your threshold that,
and then you multiply it by
matrix again, and
then your threshold that.
So you do a thresholding
after each step.
So the thresholding
can be a rounding
to the set like a complete
projection to your set,
or you choose
a close point in your set,
or just some thresholding
or some softening,
but not necessarily going
to the set of permutations.
Something that you
can also do is,
here you know that,
the multiplication
of Gamma times v,
and if you look
at the position t,
then you get
this multiplication of
the matrix times the vector
is going to be l,
and it's the same
for all the entries.
So there is a way you can,
something that you
may want to do is
to avoid the backtracking terms,
meaning that you can think
of what the position,
what vl has in this L position
is going to affect what
Gamma v has in the position T.
And you don't- you want to avoid
backtracking in terms
meaning that you
don't want that what L
had in the previous step
affecting what l
has in future step.
It's just like some
regularization that you can do.
And this regularization
is used for this,
what they call approximate
message passing algorithms.
And in fact if you want
to remove this thing,
you can write it out as
the regular multiplication of
the matrix plus
some correction term
that comes from removing
the backtracking terms,
and this is called
the outsider term
in approximate message
passing algorithms.
But you can't compute
it explicitly.
Basically, this is
an ongoing project.
Basically, what we
do is just realize
that this projected
power iteration actually
can recover the alignment
between the graphs in
some specific setting.
So here we can say it's
an experiment where a
is an Erdos Renyi graph.
You take two nodes in
your graph and you say with
probability here one half
independently there
is an edge or not.
And b is a plus some noise,
where with some probability,
you change a zero to a
one and a one to a zero.
We see that the eigenline
algorithm will recover
perfectly the matching between
this a and b if
the noise is zero.
If it's not zero then you
can see that this gray,
it's like the proportion
of the recovered matchings.
And here we do
the same with the
projected power iteration.
So basically, what
we're doing is
some regularized spectrum method
where we add this
number tracking term and
we observed that it actually
performs better than the simple.
>> Just one term was
missing from the cell.
Can you go back?
>> Yes.
>>So what is this? So
the only difference
is that L is not
equal to capital T.
>> Yes.
>> So why do you think that
this backtracking element?
There's no future here.
You mentioned like
you're maybe not
making the same influence
in the future,
but we're only talking about
two consecutive
iterations right?
>> So you can like one step,
you don't go back one step.
You can think of you have
the sequence b one, b etc,
and then what you
imagine is that
the b in the entry i affects
what the b in the entry,
what the next b in
the entry j will be.
And what you don't want
is to it affect to itself.
>> Is it like removing
self loops from.
>> Yes.
>>Like random words?
>> But even if you have that,
does it impact the performance?
I mean, if that works, we can
still have [inaudible] works.
And self loops, it
shouldn't affect too much.
Of course, it depends.
So, is it really very
crucial for you to
remove this backtracking?
>> Well, numerically,
we have said
that it improves
the performance.
But, basically this- Yes? Yes?
>> Would approach like this work
well in the sparse setting,
like if you have sparse
random graph versus
sparse random graph with noise?
I don't know if you have
like two social networks,
can you like unite them,
and figure out is it
the same set of people?
I'm just thinking what
applications of that could be.
So [inaudible] dense case.
>> Yes. This is a dense case.
Basically, we consider
this setting because
something that you need is
that the graph doesn't have
symmetries in order for
this approach to work.
Because if the graphs
have symmetries,
then you cannot hope
to recover anything.
So with high probability,
if you have a graph with this.
You don't need the t so high,
but Erdos Renyi graphs comes -.
>> [inaudible].
>> So I think that if the graph
doesn't have symmetries,
then an approach like this will
work when there's no noise.
And then it's possible that
this approach will do better.
>> The same approach
in this will work.
So here in these two graphs,
you didn't even introduce
the permutation of the nodes.
Of course, with
this kind of data,
one could have
an algorithm that cheats,
but I think your algorithm-
I would want- like
don't apply like
a random permutation to
the nodes before
you compare a and b.
>> Yes.
But it doesn't matter.
I mean you will recover
your record of the permutation.
If you have a permutation,
and you don't have noise,
then you will recover
the permutation.
>> So that [inaudible] cause
even without noise you have
the graph isomorphism problem.
So it's a hard problem.
>> Yes. But this
is the case where
the graph isomorphism
problem is easy.
>> So you are saying that
if b would be a plus noise,
and then run the
permutation it will still
give the same plot, just
because of [inaudible].
>> The algorithm is invariant.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> If there is no permutation,
you could think of
other algorithms that
would do very well.
>> Yes.
>> So, in order to
understand this algorithm
and this ongoing project that
I'm working with
Alfonso Bandeira who.
Okay. Is to understand
what this approximate
message passing will,
what is the threshold
for recovery for
this approximate message passing
algorithm in this context.
This is known for
the stochastic block model,
but these are different,
harder problems
and we'll see if we
can use the techniques that they
use for predicting
the threshold for
recovery in the
stochastic block model
for this particular problem.
And how does this compare to
this statistical threshold?
Like where the problem
is statistically
possible but the algorithm
doesn't work.
And something else
that I wanted to talk
about and I'll do it fast,
is another approach that
is see if you can use
graph neural networks to
learn the solutions of
problems of this form.
So, this is something
that I worked with Afonso,
Alex and Joan at NYU,
and Joan is an expert
in neural networks.
So, basically, some
holistically what one can say is
that the neural
network architecture
resembles these
projected power iteration
in a very high level way.
That is the, you have
a linear application and then
you have a non-linear step,
a linear application and
non-linear step, et cetera.
And then in the neural network,
you're given some data
that you want to,
data that you use for
learning and then you use
stochastic gradient descent to
match entries X and output Y,
and then you want to minimize
the loss function that here,
you consider
the non-linear steps,
then your non-linear
functions are fixed.
And the linear functions is
something that you learn.
And the success of
these algorithms depends
on the landscape of
this loss function to
be nice and to allow
stochastic gradient
descent to converge
to a good local minima
in some way,
and that the learned function
achieves the small
generalization error.
So, here,
whether what we are going
to consider is A is a graph,
and M is a set of operators
of the graph, the identity,
the degree and then powers
of the adjacency matrix
of the graph,
and then what we are
going to find is,
we are going to say, okay.
The step t+1 of a vector,
the application t+1 of
this vector is going to be,
what you learn is
a way of combining
the operators of the graph
and multiply them but.
So, you apply these operators in
this V and then
this theta is the parameters
that you learn.
So, basically, what
you're learning is
the way you combine
these operators for the graph.
Like for example,
you can think of
a spectral method that
is like a regularized
spectral method.
So, you have alpha,
times identity, plus
beta, times the degree,
plus Gamma, times
erlang poisson,
and that is something
that you can use for
example, for clustering.
And here, what you're learning
is how you combine this degree,
with what these alpha,
beta and Gamma will be.
But, here in this set
of neural networks,
the set of parameters
is much larger.
And the set of operator.
So, you're gonna see it's
going to be much larger.
And so, these are
trainer or parameters,
and what you do is.
>> Are you subscripting
to those vectors.
this n, i, what is
the I index in there?
>> This one?
Okay. So, this vector is not
going to be just one vector,
it's going to be a matrix that
is going to be like
an embedding of your graph.
So, L is
the number of columns.
>> So, that's when Ds are,
when the DTs are at one
there's neural network.
So, this is like one channel or
a vector version
of neural network.
>> It's a no.
>> So, the linear part is
going to be this theta.
>> How do you
match this for
your neural network?
>> Okay. So, we've set M,
if set like put in your graph
M as just identity,
what would it be? Does
[inaudible] graph?
>> All right.
So, then you have just one
weighted layer and it's not,
okay. So, it's not interesting.
>> So, what's
the point of having L?
I understand
the integration but.
>> Okay. So, you just
learn an embedding of
your graph to dt.
That's right.
>> So, precisely if your set
has just identity it
could be neuron neural network.
>> No. I don't think so.
You just have
one weight, it's just.
>> No, you have dt
weight per layer.
>> Dt by dt
>> No. But M means.
>> This sign is only over M.
>> Okay. So, it's like L
independent coordinates?
>> Yes. Okay. Never mind.
So, basically, what you do is
you learn embeddings for graphs,
and then you want to
minimize the loss of
how the outer product
of this embedding,
the embedding of A,
and the embedding
of B, being close to identity.
>> Yes. But the one thing
we didn't understand was,
how is the different L
coordinates interacting?
Is there any credential for p?
>> You can think
of it, instead of
taking the top eigenvector,
you can take like K top
eigenvectors for your graphs.
>> So, dt is the vector
comprising of all these vlt
plus vlt for L
over 1 to d plus 1?
>> So, T is the layer,
the layer that you are in.
>> T is the layer.
But vt though which is in there,
is that a matrix that
comprise the columns vlt?
>> Yes.
>> No.
But then it's multiplied
by theta T mn. Yes. But.
So, these are not
independent [inaudible]?
>> [inaudible] there is
no subscript [inaudible].
>> Okay.
>> So, it's kind of
like you're learning
how each of the columns
of B T will be,
as a combination of
the data of this form.
So, if it was only have l = 1 ,
then you will only have one kind
of like eigenvector
for your data.
>> So, just my question again.
So, if [inaudible] just have
identity and now that we
understood their
interactions that
would just be like
usual neural networks?
>> Agree.
>> Yes.
>> Good.
>> Okay.
>> So, here what you're doing,
is you are learning a way to
combine the operators
for the graph.
The operators that you
care about the graph.
So, in particular
this architecture
is invariant to permutations.
So, if I have
a permutation in A,
like if I permute two rows of A,
rows and columns of A, then what
happens is that you obtain
the same permutation in B.
So, is invariant to
permutations in that sense.
Right? So, in particular,
you can just think
that you want to
learn the entity and if
you have a permutation,
then you will learn
the permutation that you want.
So, you learn an embedding
for A and embedding for
B and if you know that you
want to match A with B,
then the loss function
that you want to
use is the KL divergence of
how far away is
this outter probe of embedding
A and B with the identity.
And you can train this with
A as training graph and B,
A plus noise and
see how it performs.
And the way it
performs is, okay,
so here the noise level in the Y
axis that [inaudible] and we have
that the [inaudible]
is the red one and
then the graph
neural network is the
green one and the black one
is the projected,
probably duration, for
this particular model
where the matching is not hard.
And so,another thing
that we want to do is to
see the traveling
salesman problem
with this graph neural networks.
So, we can do it in two ways.
One way is to use
input of the graph and
the ground truth of
the traveling salesman cycle
to train the model like,
okay, given the graph, this
is the Traveling
salesman problem,
let's say that you
find it within an
heuristic and you want to see if
your graph neural network
can learn that.
And the other
possible way to do it,
is you can see the minimizing
of the course of the break to
cycle as the lost function.
So which one do you
think will be better?
>> So the first one
is [inaudible].
>> Let's say, that you have
an oracle that gives you
the solution from the
traveling salesman problem and
then you have a graph,
plan to solution and then you
will want to match that
or the other one is
you just take the length
of the path as the cost.
>> Both cases, the hope is to
adapt to some
distribution on graphs.
>> Yes.
Of course, you need to have
the distribution graphs
in order to train your,
or maybe you have
data, a lot of data.
So, in fact what we view,
it seems like the second one
would be more natural,
but we did the first one because
this cost that break the cycle,
is non differential with
respect to the parameters.
>> You are actually
solving a strictly
harder problem.
So, the second approach
you're solving
the harder problem [inaudible]
because you are trying
to be able to predict the course
of any arbritary part of
the graph but
you're trying to get
a predictor and then what
do is like post process.
Through this predictor,
you want to now,
search through
all possible paths
and find the shortest path.
So, all I need to know is
something that predicts
the shortest path and I
don't need to have to have
a predictor that can predict
the course of
any possible cycle.
>> Yes.
>> Round about way of
getting what we want.
>> Yes
>> So, basically with that,
we train it with
this Oracle solution and then we
got that it works in some sense.
It's not not optimal and also
the predictor cycles
do not look exactly
like the target cycles
but they look close,
which is interesting and I
don't know how to explain it
but, yes. So, basically.
>> But you think [inaudible]
>> No, it wouldn't be that good.
So the question is,
can you learn it?
Yes, but at least in
the way we have it,
it's not a school.
>> [inaudible] is it like random
geometric graph or something.
>> Yes, random.
>> Those things are very
easy for GSP in general.
It's like anything
works well on those.
These gaps of two percent
and one percent
it's not very different.
>> Maybe line neural
network problem
would not have work
with [inaudible]
>> No, no. Yeah, yeah.
>> Yes, I agree.
>> [inaudible] which in the
worst case gives [inaudible].
>> Oh [inaudible].
>> Okay, things that I'm
working on we were in with
the experts we have there,
is to understand this
approximate message passing from
no backtracking Spectrometers
like in that case the
second part of
the problem and see this
the statistical model signal
plus noise and see
the thresholds for recovery
and try to understand
this graph neural networks,
why they can learn?
What kind of things
they can learn,
how will they
perform, et cetera.
And the local minima
of these kind
of problems and just that.
This is it.
>> Okay, so [inaudible]
is going to be here
for the rest of
the day and tomorrow,
so if you have a question,
I think that she's here.
>> Would you like
to show us that TV?
>> Yes, I will. It's not like I.